I want to bring in Max Boot now.
He's a senior
fellow at the Council
on Foreign Relations.
He has a new column
in The Washington Post,
and he writes that while it's great,
The Grinder is back home,
the hostage bazaar has to close.
John Avlon, Margaret
Hoover are back with us also.
So, Max,
when you say the hostage bazaar
has to end, meaning prisoner swaps.
Yeah.
I mean, there's just been
so many in recent years.
And it's kind of ironic
to see
former President
Trump and his supporters
attacking this deal
when Donald Trump himself bragged
that he was the greatest
hostage negotiator in human history.
He made a lot of press.
He made a lot of prisoner swaps
with the Taliban or the Houthis
with a lot of repugnant regimes.
And this has been a trend going back
many years now.
And you know, the problem
is that each individual case,
our hearts go out to that.
We want to see these Americans come home
because they are being unjustly detained.
The problem is
when we are making all these deals,
making all these concessions,
including letting somebody
like Victor Boot,
this notorious arms dealer
out of prison to get somebody else
who was unjustly detained home
it creates incentives
to seize more American hostages.
Understand.
But what's the option?
Let Brittney Griner
stay in a Russian penal colony.
No, I mean, I'm
very glad that Brittney Griner is up,
but I think we need to have a
serious debate
about whether we want
to continue doing this
or whether we should say,
you know,
the State
Department has a list of countries
where advises Americans not to travel,
including Russia, Iran, Syria,
some of the obvious candidates.
And maybe at some point
we need to have a president
who says,
okay, I'm
going to work to get the people out
who are currently in prison.
But in the future,
if you choose to go to Russia,
you are on your own.
We are not going to make concessions
to get you home.
And by the way,
I might add there
still like 30 American basketball players
who are still playing in Russia
as we speak.
That is not very wise.
That is creating the potential
for yet another hostage
crisis down the road.
What I think is fascinating about it
is the idea of
and some people will ask the question,
but they'll say, well,
and I remember
when she was first detained,
we first learned about her detention
before people realize
she was a basketball player there.
They would make comments
about what someone do in there
because we remember
we learned about her during the invasion.
She'd already been detained
or questions about this person
not a traveler's place on the
do not do not travel area.
But your point really
is the idea of a hold on
if people are intending to do it anyway.
They ought
not to be able
to have the luxury
of having the government
support them and have their safe
return guaranteed.
What do you guys think about that?
I, I respectfully disagree.
I understand
the point that Max is making,
but I think that the privileges
and responsibilities
of American citizenship of government
to its citizens
don't stop
simply
because someone has found themselves
in an unwise or dangerous place.
I haven't yet seen the point
the max is making,
which is that, you know,
if you negotiate for
for one hostage,
that it creates an incentive
to get another dozen.
Now, on the surface, obviously,
trading someone whose nickname
is The Merchant of Death
for a WNBA star
who was improperly
detained is an imbalance.
But American presidents
going back
decades, as Max points out,
have made it a priority
to try to get Americans
out of harm's way.
That's a basic
responsibility of the government
and the president.
And the fact that she was being used
as a pawn
within the context of the run up
to the invasion of Ukraine.
Paul Whalen still is there.
He should be released.
But I think we need to celebrate
as Americans.
What we need to avoid
is the kind of situational ethics
we see where Republicans
who celebrated every hostage
released by Donald Trump condemn
this one is making America weaker.
It does not make us weaker.
Well, no,
I mean I mean, I agree with you.
There is massive hypocrisy
on the part of Republicans here.
There's no way around that.
But I think at the end of the day,
there is a legitimate point that these
that these hostage swaps
do make us weaker.
The problem is both parties have done it.
It's a bipartisan problem.
Margaret, what do you think?
What do you do?
I mean, I am willing to give a lot of
leeway to the people
who are in the negotiations
and who have the intelligence,
who know the details about
what was being offered
between Brittany and Paul Whalen.
I'm delighted that she's home.
Of course, we've been following it.
But if I recall, President Trump slapped
many, many dozens of Taliban prisoners,
which
which struck me as an outrage at the time
in order to get Americans back.
But you're right,
there is this precedent
for four American presidents
doing what they can
in order to get Americans back.
I was struck, frankly, that her statement
that she
she took time in her statement
to update the country about how she was,
but then to also make note of Poland,
who is still there in Russia.
And there has been a degree of criticism
about him being left behind
and some commentary about that.
I, I wasn't part of the negotiations.
I mean, basically, why don't you.
But what does that mean?
There's a lot of opportunism
there, obviously.
Because, I mean, everybody wants Paul
Whalen home.
But he was captured in 20, 18
when Donald Trump was president.
And now Trump
and others are suggesting that Biden
did something wrong by
not getting him out.
Well, why didn't Trump
get him out in the first place?
Yeah, great point.